a judge in India has heard evidence from
a woman from her hospital bed two years
after she accused the former legislator
of wait coal deep Singh Sangha is
accused of raping the woman in 2017 when
he was 15 he also faces a murder charge
over a car accident that hospitalized
the woman the trial is one of many
sexual assault cases in India that has
caused public outrage the kidnap and
rape of an eight-year-old girl in 2018
drew angry protests figures from 2016
show there were 40,000 rapes registered
an average of about a hundred a day
let's speak now to Indian Supreme Court
lawyer
mahira Sood who joins us via Skype now
from New Delhi thanks very much for
being with us so it just give us your
thoughts then on this particular case
and how it figures into the whole debate
about rape in India and this culture of
seeming culture of impunity there yes
well I think one important thing to
consider is that of all the thousands of
cases that of sexual assault that do
happen in India there there are always
going to be a few that for whatever
reason stand out grab the attention of
the media and grab the attention of the
public so I think we have to keep in
mind firstly that this case is just it's
just one of many and there are many more
stories like this that are not even
being told which should just give you an
idea of how bad the situation really is
in India and how precarious it is for
women and girls here and I think stands
out in this case in particular is the
fact that there is really no protection
for people coming forward to testify
whether they are survivors or witnesses
because what you have in this case is a
political politically powerful person
who has been able to use his power and
influence to compromise the survivors
security arrangements
and to threaten browbeat and actually
assault and in some cases kill the
witnesses and lawyers supporting her
so either through a situation of
incentivizing people to withdraw their
cases or threatening and intimidating
them to to do so what you have is a
situation where cases don't tend to get
prosecuted to their fullest extent and
that's where the political power and the
impunity really comes in because people
know that they can get away with it so
what's the solution then is it enacting
tougher laws or is it is it more than
that is it it doesn't require a whole
changing in attitude and and culture see
I think as far as laws are concerned we
have some very stringent laws on paper
but the problem lies in the their poor
implementation and the fact that you've
not really trained and sensitized the
people responsible for that
implementation whether it is the law
enforcement that is the police or
whether it is the lower judiciary where
the actual trial is conducted that is
the first first sort of point of contact
for a survivor with the legal system and
we have to remember that the people
implementing this at these levels come
from the same society as the people
actually committing these crimes so
beyond the point law is not really the
one-stop solution that it is made out to
be what we need is better social
awareness and sensitization and as far
as laws are concerned we really ought to
be focusing on better witness protection
and protection for survivors so that
they're not afraid to testify good to
speak to you mahira
soon thanks for being with us